bonjour à tous vous allez pouvoir suivre
l'audition de louis gallois devant la
mission commune d'information sur
l'impact sur l'emploi des exonérations
de charges alors louis gallois c'est
l'ancien patron de ads le monsieur
compétitivité de françois hollande c'est
celui qui réclame hélène dernière un
choc justement de compétitivité
permettant d'alléger les charges
patronales et salariales aujourd'hui où
en est-on le pacte de responsabilité a
été annoncé qu'elle va être en effet sur
les entreprises et sur l'emploi louis
gallois tentent de répondre à toutes ces
questions devant les sénateurs lorsque
l'on cible les réductions de charges sur
les bas salaires
on a un effet emploi assez fort
mais qui est répartie sur l'ensemble du
champ des acteurs économiques y compris
ceux qui emploient beaucoup de monde qui
ne sont pas le temps d'en exposer la
concurrence internationale
et grandes surfaces et autres
en revanche si on
privilégie des emplois ou si on permet
des exonérations
portant sur des rémunérations plus
élevées on diminue l'impact sur l'emploi
et ont normalement on a un impact plus
ciblée sur l'industrie qui elle même
mais plus exposés à la concurrence
internationale
donc on cible plus l'impact sur le les
l'industrie
j'avais d'ailleurs expliqué que
les allégements que je proposais qui
portait sur les charges sociales et pas
sur le crédit d'impôt mais enfin c'est
du second ordre
viser surtout à donner un ballon
d'oxygène aux entreprises
pour
les remettre dans une dynamique
d'investissement
et j'avais donc souhaité que ce soient
ciblées plutôt sur l'industrie c'est
pour ça que j'avais proposé que ce soit
au moins jusqu'à trois fois et demie le
smic
et le gouvernement comme vous l'avez dit
d'ailleurs fort justement je ne peux que
paraphraser vos propos choisi une
solution mais moyenne entre les deux
avec deux fois et demie le smic
avec un effet couperet
c'est à dire que une rémunération qui
est de 2 x 6 smic n'a droit à aucun
allègement ce qui
m'a toujours posé question
j'aurais préféré que l'on ait un
au moins que mais bien évidemment ça
accroît c'est le coût de la mesure mais
que
la l'exonération la réduction de charges
soit acquise
de toute façon en dessous de ce seuil de
deux fois et demie et la partie de la
rémunération rhodes sud deux fois et
demie n'en bénéficiant pas
alors on peut aborder le sujet de deux
manières
la première c'est celle qui résulte
d'une étude que la dg 6 c'est à dire les
services de monsieur montebourg ont
demandé au procès ragga mais je ne sais
pas si ces processus et travaux ont été
portées à votre attention si donc
si on transférait la totalité des
charges des allocations familiales 32
milliards à la charge des entreprises
actuellement si on est transféré la
totalité sur la fiscalité
l'effet serait de 62000 création
d'emplois
et on à croître et
cet effort si on le sait ce résultat en
termes de création d'emplois si on le
focaliser plus sur les bas salaires
je vais vous dire que je suis incapable
de vérifier ce chiffre
de 62 mille emplois
il est en tout cas fondé sur une
hypothèse de croissance qui est décisive
et j'en viens à ma deuxième
deuxième aspect qui est
d'examiner ce cas l'impact du cic et
là je pense que vous avez bénéficié des
travaux du de l'insee fait à la demande
du commissariat général
stratégie et à prospectifs
une enquête sur 8000 entreprises peu
près la moitié de ces entreprises ont
répondu
et vous connaissez le résultat les
entreprises ayant droit à plusieurs
réponses ça fera plus de 100 % mais 46%
l'affect à la croissance de
l'investissement
31% à l'emploi 21% au prix à la baisse
du prix de vente et 20% l'augmentation
des salaires dans l'industrie et dans
les services ces 53 % la croissance de
l'investissement 43% l'emploi
29 % la baisse du prix de vente et 38% à
l'augmentation des salaires je déduis
d'ailleurs de ceux de répondre au
questionnaire que les gens du service en
très mal répondu ils ont dit oui à tout
ils ont coché toutes les cases
et donc je ne trouve pas ça très
pertinent du côté des services vous le
dis comme je le pense
et encore une fois je ne suis pas un
économètre mais je dois peu suspect que
de voir que
ils ont répondu ou pratiquement oui à
toutes les avec un petit bémol sur la
réduction des prix de vente
ce qui d'ailleurs n'est pas surprenant
pour les services fils qui sont peu
exposés à la cua la compétition
internationale
je suis plus sensible à ce que le
répondu l'industrie qui m'a paru avoir
est un peu plus sélective
mais alors on constate qu'en gros un
tiers des entreprises en gros tiers des
entreprises
affecteront le bénéfice du ceis yeux à
la création d'emplois si on en lit tout
au moins d'une partie de l' avantage
c'est ici à la création d'emplois
je dois vous dire que pour moi je ne
crois absolument pas aux effets
mécaniques
les entreprises embaucheront si elles
ont un certain degré de confiance dans
la croissance
qui leur permettra
de nourrir ses emplois
on constate d'ailleurs que si les
entreprises sont optimistes la
conjoncture
elles répondent
beaucoup plus positivement sur la
création d'emplois 15 points de plus à
la création d'emplois que les
entreprises qui sont qui en jugement
négatif sur la conjoncture donc la
conjoncture introduit un élément
absolument décisif dans la création
d'emplois
je retire de cela mais peut-être me
trompé-je
que l'effet le plus solide du cicr va km
sur l'investissement
et que le reste est beaucoup plus
aléatoire et dépend vraiment de la
conjoncture économique
et d'ailleurs ça ne me déplaît pas parce
que c'était quand même ce que je
souhaitais lorsque j'ai proposé la
mesure c'est peut-être pour ça
d'ailleurs que je te tire les
statistiques de ce côté là donc j'ai
peut-être un billet mais là je constate
quand même que c'est ce qui est le plus
solide c'est l'investissement qui les
perspectives sur l'investissement bouge
beaucoup moins en fonction de la
conjoncture que les perspectives sur
l'emploi qui
que pas une surprise est beaucoup plus
dépendants d'eux
de la situation économique de
l'entreprise se doute ses perspectives
de croissance
je peux pas aller beaucoup plus loin
soif à déborder largement le sujet est
abordé tous les points de la
compétitivité vous même avez demandé
d'abord d'un point du dialogue social
c'est un autre sujet je suis tout à fait
prêt à le faire
je
c'était à la fois incidemment mais
peut-être aurez-vous à l'occasion d'une
autre question
sur les dispositions doubles pour
répondre sur ce sujet qui m'a toujours
les intéressés étant dévolue à les faire
l'entreprise
bien donc je vous remercie tout d'abord
on se présentait donc je vais passer la
parole à notre rapporteur madame de
messine qui je pense va vous allez plus
loin un peu et va vous pousser dans vos
retranchements mais
disons toute façon on est intéressé
aussi par le concept de compétitivité
puisque c'est quand même
par ricochet c'est quand même le sujet
que nous abordons
donc je vais revenir sur la question que
vous avez abordé vous avez répondu en
partie mon peut peut-être un petit peu
la creuse et dans votre célèbre rapport
on peut le dire de novembre 2012 sera la
compétitivité vous avez écrit et je vous
cite les allégements effectué depuis 20
ans concernés les plus bas salaires et
ont pour cette raison très peu impacté
directement l'industrie qui se situe à
des rémunérations plus élevées vous
venez de le rappeler pour atteindre de
manière privilégiée l'industrie et les
services à haute valeur ajoutée qui lui
sont liés
bureau d'études d'ingénierie
informatique conseil il conviendrait que
le transfert de charges portent sur les
salaires jusqu'à trois fois et demie le
smic dans ces conditions vous avez dit à
l'époque 35% de l' avantage créerez
irait directement vers l'industrie et
les services à haute valeur ajoutée
associée alors estimez vous que le cic
combiné aux récentes annonces
gouvernementales vont dans ce sens je
pense que vous l'avez un peu dit en
rajoutant que vous espériez qu'ils
aillent à l'investissement et il
semblerait que c'est plutôt vers ce sens
encore qu'aujourd'hui on ne peut pas
encore l'affirmer
et dans les auditions et je rajoutais
dans les conditions que nous avons eues
notamment avec la bpi qui est le la
banque de préfinancement
dans les demandes de préfinancement qui
sont pas
qui reflète pas complètement
le le comportement mais
globalement
grande partie ces préfinancement l'ont
été demandée pour répondre des problèmes
de trésorerie
donc il ya aussi cet aspect locke il
faut qu'il faut prendre en compte
surtout quand la situation continue à ne
pas aller très bien ça c'est la première
question
deuxièmement dans le même temps vous
avez souligné les effets dits de second
tour en vertu desquels un allègement de
charges sur les bas salaires a pour
conséquence une amélioration de la
compétitivité des secteurs à salaire
élevé en raison de l'abaissement général
des coûts de production donc on entend
bien ça mais est il possible de
quantifier ses effets
troisième question à quelles conditions
les exonérations de charges sociales
peuvent elles constituer un levier
efficace pour permettre une montée en
gamme ne se trompe pas de combat dès
lors que la montée en gamme industrielle
devrait nous conduire à raisonner en
compétitivité hors prix
dans les autres pays notamment
l'allemagne puis c'est un sujet qui
revient tous les jours
de manière récurrente
quels ont été les leviers sociaux et
fiscaux
utilisés pour favoriser depuis 20 ans
cet appareil industriel à forte valeur
ajoutée vous avez certainement un avis
sur cette question et enfin
des dispositifs incitatifs sur le plan
fiscal comme d armor tissement
dérogatoires où le crédit d'impôt
recherche ne sont ils pas plus adapté
peut-on mesurer l'impact sur l'emploi
direccte et et indique avec du crédit
impôt recherche
est qualifiée requalifié rire vous la
france comme on le lit parfois de
paradis fiscal pour la recherche
première salve et puis on abordera
apprend ensuite la question de la
compétitivité de certains sujets madame
jeu
je maintiens
ce que je vous ai dit c'est à dire que
si on veut focaliser sur un esprit la
courbe gelée par apporter mais je n'ai
pas à porter mais les jeunes gens
disposent la courbe qui mesure
l'impact sur l'industrie en fonction du
seuil qui est retenu du niveau maximum
d'exonération on plafonne à trois quand
on est à trois je vois à trois ennemis
fois le smic on a
une part de l'industrie qui que j'ai
chiffre est à peu près à 35% et qui
n'augmentent plus vraiment on passe
peut-être si on allait à 6 fois on
passerait peut-être de 35 à 37% tron on
est près de la symptômes comme on dirait
en mathématiques alors que entre deux
fois et demie et trois fois et demi il
ya une grosse différence assez nette je
n'ai pas le chiffre en tête mais je
dirais qu'avec deux fois et demie on est
plutôt autour de 25 % coton 35% mais
ceux-ci mériteraient d'être vérifiées et
je ne veux pas m'engager sur ce chiffre
donc je reste convaincu que si on veut
traiter le point de la compétitivité des
secteurs exposés à la concurrence et du
secteur industriel auquel je suis
particulièrement attachée parce que
j'estime que c'est la fine pointe de la
compétitivité d'un pays
je pense que il y fallait où il faudrait
aller au delà de deux fois et demie le
smic
l'intérêt d'un transfert des allocations
familiales
même s'il ya des plafonnements c'est que
ça touche tous les salaires
et donc je trouvais que c'était mieux
adaptés d'autant plus que
sur le plan théorique faire supporter à
l'appareil de production
des éléments de solidarité nationale qui
relève
normalement de l'impôt comme les
la politique de la famille ne me
paraissait pas
totalement ça me paraissait pas
totalement justifié de le faire porter
par les entreprises
quant au seul a été créé en 45 qu'ils
avaient la capacité contributive n'était
que dans les entreprises et donc on a
pris cette base parce que c'était celle
qui existait
je pense que actuellement la fiscalité
c'est
suffisamment diversifiée pour que l'on
puisse envisager d'autres d'autres
supports vous avez raison de dire que le
crédit d'impôt d'abord le crédit d'impôt
le cic eux c'est bien joli mais les
entreprises ne l'ont pas encore touché
c'est sur le premier acompte de l'impôt
sur les sociétés que ça concède déduit
donc c'est de ces jours ci donc ce
qu'elle les entreprises il ya d'autres
ont fait appel aux préfinancements et
vous l'avez comme l'a rappelé le
rapporteur
souligné
les entreprises qui ne font pas l'objet
financement sont celles qui ont des
besoins de trésorerie
puisque ce préfinancement et coûteux
vous n'avez peut-être pas demandé la bpi
qui a été le taux d'intérêt sur ce
préfinancement
et bien écoutez ce n'est pas ce qui est
vérifiée dans les provinces où on me
donne des chiffres plus élevés et qui en
plus dépendre parce que ce n'est pas
louis pardon oui deux à quatre selon la
taille des entreprises et donc quand
vous avez une inflation à 0 quand vous
avez une inflation à 0,5 0,7
ce sont des taux d'intérêt réels qui ne
sont pas négligeables donc les
entreprises qui ont des trésoreries ne
font pas appel aux préfinancements
ce sont celles qui ont des besoins de
financement dont qui je dirais que c'est
presque la démonstration que ce sont les
centristes ont après notre série est
effectivement pour une entreprise
les problèmes de trésorerie sont pas
savons tous les autres
quand on en trouvait à plus de
trésorerie elle ne peut plus vivre donc
dès lors qu'il dépend de trésorerie tout
est bon pour alimenter sa trésorerie y
compris le préfinancement
ses yeux parce que les entreprises ont
des bosses trésorerie quand elle vole en
banque youth avec les dons qui offre des
parapluies quand il fait beau patron il
pleut
je ne reprendrai pas cette expression un
procès-verbal parce que j'ai beaucoup
d'amis banquiers mais
on voit bien qu actuellement les
entreprises ont quelques difficultés à
se financer
j'ai compris d'ailleurs que monsieur
montebourg les avait réunis pour leur
demander de traits plus actifs dans ce
domaine
voilà ce que je vous réponde sur la
première question sur la quantification
des effets encore une fois
l'effet sur l'emploi à mon avis est très
dépendant du taux de croissance que l'on
retient et l'effet sur l'investissement
il faudrait savoir tout le problème dans
ces affaires-là c'est de connaître la
base c'est qu'est ce qui se serait passé
s'il n'y avait pas de crédit n'y avait
pas eu de cice
jeu
s'il ya une augmentation de
l'investissement 2014 ce que les
économistes prévoient
qu'elle part devrait être attribuée au
cicr ses défenseurs voulu attribuer une
part importante
d'autres peut-être moins je constate
néanmoins que c'est le sujet le thème
qui est le plus retenu par les
entreprises des services et de
l'industrie lorsqu'en de lens qui vont
faire du cic
j'ai noté d'ailleurs qu'on leur posait
pas la question de savoir s'il n'existe
à leurs actionnaires mais bon on leur a
posé quatre questions passées on aurait
pu leur poser une cinquième bon donc je
ne suis pas capable de vous répondre
si ce n'est ces éléments qui me conduise
à penser que ça peut soutenir
l'investissement
vous dites l'exonération des charges
sociales traitent un problème de
compétitivité coût la montée en gamme
ses hors coûts pour monter en gamme il
faut investir
il faut investir il ya deux sujets dans
l'industrie française actuellement qui
sont un obstacle à la croissance
potentielle de la france c'est d'abord
des gains de productivité très faibles
nous avons une bonne productivité mais
la preuve mais cette productivité
s'érode du fait que les gains de
productivité annuelle sont très faibles
actuellement parce que les entreprises
n'investissent pas assez
c'est devenu maintenant un lieu commun
que de dire que nous avons 35 mille
robots en france que l'italie en a 62
milles et l'allemagne 150000 et que les
générations de robots en france sont
plus anciennes que la génération de
robots en italie et en allemagne
je pense qu'il ya un gain des gains de
productivité ont été sont insuffisants
parce que l'investissement est
insuffisant les deuxièmement
l'innovation est un élément aussi de
monter en gamme et de et d'augmentation
de la croissance potentielle et
l'innovation coûte de l'argent il faut
dépenser de l'argent pour innover parce
que vous faire de la recherche et c'est
donc la montée en gamme c'est hors coûts
c'est vrai c'est même pour sortir de là
du piège des prix
on n'achète pas une bmw parce qu'elle
est bon marché
est ce que pour pour être un peu abrupte
la problématique que l'on a en france
jeudi rentrer ce création d'emplois ou
compétitivité etc ne repose-t-elle pas
sur le fait que nous avons une
spécificité c'est à dire que nous avons
un smic relativement fort et qui est
quand même hors marché que tout notre
système social et quand même ainsi sur
la partie salaires et donc comme vous
l'avez dit tout à l'heure sur les
entreprises et que de surcroît ce niveau
de protection sociale et est en plus
très haut ce dont on ne va pas se
plaindre mais il est assis là dessus et
alors est ce que en fait toutes les
solutions qu'on essaie de discuter ne re
ne sont pas quelques fois là pour
compenser cet état de choses dans un
monde un petit peu globalisé
de l'élément coup la compétitivité est
évidemment quand on parle d'exonérations
de charges sociales de réduction de la
fiscalité sur les entreprises c'est pour
traiter ce point de
l'élément de coups alors toutes les
comparaisons internationales existent
sur ces éléments de coûts sur le coût du
travail cetera moi je me suis gardé
d'aborder ce problème sous l'aspect coût
du travail parce que pourquoi je pense
j'en ai parlé du coût du travail il
parle du coût de la fiscalité du coût de
l'énergie
j'ai seulement dit je constate que les
marges des entreprises sont extrêmement
basses
je constate que les maris sont
extrêmement basses et qu'elles ont
besoin de bande à bonnot d'oxygène à la
fois pour retrouver confiance et pour ré
enclenché un processus d'investissement
c'est comme cela que je vais présenter
vous ne trouverez pas dans mon rapport
l'expression que du travail ce qui ne
veut pas dire que je considère pas que
ce soit un problème
mais je me suis dit si je parle du coût
du travail il faut que je parle de tous
les coûts et pas uniquement du coût du
travail les coûts financiers les coûts
les coûts fiscaux etc donc
je j'ai bien parlé de ballon d'oxygène
pour les entreprises
et
toute ma thèse c'est qu'il faut
justement
sortir
une partie de l'industrie française de 2
dans une compétition par les prix
qui l'étranglent
et pour sortir de la compétition par les
prix faut créer d'autres avantages que
le prix c'est ce que l'industrie
allemande a fait magnifiquement sur les
biens d'équipement on achète des biens
d'équipement non parce qu'il y en a pas
d'autre
les automobiles allemandes sont plus
chers qu'ils obéissent française je vous
donne un exemple
entre volkswagen et une voiture
française à quelques caractéristiques
égales la volkswagen coûts de 10% plus
cher
parce que les gens avaient acheté une
grosse graine et c'est cet élément qu'il
faut qu'on soit capable de créer en
france sur nos sur nos productions sans
trahir de secret il ya une entreprise
française qui est un bon exemple c'est
michelin michelin vasep le plus cher que
les autres
mais on achète les pneus michelin parce
qu'on veut avoir des pneus michelin
parce qu'on sait que sont les meilleurs
mais vous imaginez davantage que ça
donne une entreprise dans la compétition
internationale de pouvoir vendre plus
cher que les autres
et je pense que c'est ça que nous devons
essayer alors je dis pas que ça pourra
concerner la totalité de l'industrie
mais ça peut
intéresser
des secteurs beaucoup plus large de
notre industrie
sur les leviers fiscaux et sociaux en
allemagne
il ya des éléments sur les leviers
fiscaux
la fiscalité des entreprises et un
niveau plus - plus bas que la fiscalité
française fiscalité charges sociales
assez assez sensiblement plus bas tout
les calculs ont été faits je vais pas
les refaire
ce qui veut dire que les ménages
al'inverse paye plus c'est pareil pour
l'électricité il ya un transfert
d'électricité des tarifs du coût de
l'électricité en allemagne des
entreprises vers les ménages
ceci est facilitée par une chose
c'est que le logement représente 16 % du
revenu des allemands et 26 % de revenus
des français
je pense que nous avons j'ai regretté je
lui ai dit plusieurs fois de ne pas voir
traiter ce problème dans mon rapport je
les eaux me dire c'est une erreur de ma
part parce que je pense que c'est un
élément tout à fait décisif qui
fait que les ménages français leur
capacité contributive j'allais dire ce
pot pour autre chose pour l'énergie pour
la fiscalité autre chose est limitée par
le fait qu'ils consomment énormément
pour le jour
avec un coût du logement qui est un
handicap l'ensemble de la société
française
alors ça c'est les dons des allemands
mieux résolu ce problème que nous
quant aux sur le plan social
l'allemagne a créé à la suite des
réformes hartz deux marchés du travail
complètement de séparer
un premier marché du travail qui est
celui
des grandes entreprises ou des
entreprises du mittal jeudi 8 du
mittelstand avec des organisations
syndicales extrêmement puissante que
j'ai pu
mesurer
quand vous avez une grève chez airbus à
hambourg il ya 98 % de grévistes c'est à
dire que tout le monde et ça s'arrête
tout s'arrête
donc vous avez des syndicats forts qui
ont établi un rapport de force avec les
organisations patronales fondés sur un
dialogue social beaucoup plus riche
qu'en france
nous y voilà beaucoup plus riche qu'en
france et qui qui est à mon avis gagnant
gagnant je le dis franchement mais qui
concerne une partie du salariat est ce
qu a introduit art dans ses réformes
c'est un deuxième partie une
précarisation total d'une partie du
monde du travail avec des contrats
évidemment à temps parce beaucoup de
temps partiel
beaucoup pas de salaire minimum des
salaires et des dés des salaires
extrêmement bas qui sont entre 1 4 5
euros ce qui conduit d'ailleurs les
collectivités territoriales à faire le
complément j'appelle ça de la subvention
l'industrie mois
suivant sur l'économie parce que quand
vous payez un salarié dans les abattoirs
allemands 4 euros et que ce salarié pour
joindre les deux bouts est obligé de
demander l'aide sociale et collective à
la coller d'une collectivité
c'est une sorte de subvention indirecte
aux abattoirs allemands il faut pas
s'étonner si nos
bateaux absous feront eux qui sont
soumis à la dure loi monsieur le
président que vous évoquiez du salaire
minimum bon donc vous avez
et ça c'est un avantage considérable
c'est un avantage considérable parce que
ça ne concerne pas l'industrie ça ne
concerne pas l'industrie exportatrice
les abattoirs étant une exception ça
concerne mais ça concerne des secteurs
qui se font que
les produits
ça réduit c'est un avantage indirect
pour l'industrie parce que ça crée un
environnement de services et de produits
bon marché dont bénéficient les
entreprises où les salariés des
entreprises
est riche et par exemple me disait
tu peux pas savoir en europe francfort
la vie est moins cher qu'à paris que que
dans les villes françaises
je pense qu'une des raisons pour
lesquelles c'est moins cher c'est parce
que une partie des salaires sont situées
très en dessous de ce que nous appelons
le ser minimes et d'ailleurs c'est pour
cela que on va regarder avec beaucoup
d'attention ce que font les allemands
sur le salaire minimum et comment il va
être mis en place dans les différentes
branches
m'avait interrogé ensuite sur
les des mesures plus ciblées en faveur
l'industrie par exemple
l'amortissement accéléré
un
traitement fiscal privilégié des
investissements etc on peut tout à fait
imaginer je vais vous dire que lorsque
j'avais évoqué mais dans mon rapport les
allégements cette question était venu
j'en avais eu l'occasion d'en débattre
avec tel ou tel sur ce sujet j'avais
préféré une mesure générale visible qui
parce que je pensais qu'il fallait créer
un effet un petit défi de choc et que je
pensais que on le crée mieux à travers
une mesure générale qu'à travers des
mesures partielles mais ceci est tout à
fait peut tout à fait
discuter et le débat est réel moi je
suis assez favorable à l'amortissement
accéléré des investissements
le crédit d'impôt recherche
j'en suis un défenseur acharné
avec une théorie qui est
enfin qui fondait sur mon expérience qui
est que
pour les petites entreprises ça leur a
permis de maintenir l'effort de
recherche pendant la crise à un niveau
correct et vous savez que les
entreprises françaises
dépensent au moins autant recherche
un secteur donné et à y donner que les
entreprises allemandes ou autre
et c'est alors qu'elles ont des marges
beaucoup plus basses basse c'est
largement dû au clean impôt recherche et
quant aux grandes entreprises
le seul l'impact du crédit impôt
recherche et qu'elles localisent leurs
recherches en france et pas ailleurs
et je peux vous dire que ça a été le cas
de la neige
nous sommes nous avons implanté des
activités de recherche en france
grâce au crédit d'impôt recherche on n'a
pas fait plus de recherche à cause de ça
mais on a fait en france parce qu'il ya
une véritable compétition internationale
sur la localisation des centres de
recherche actuellement
et que les anglais en particulier
déroule le tapis rouge
sur
pour pour attirer les centres de
recherche des entreprises et je pense
que c'est un élément dans la compétition
internationale
vous avez ample expression paradis
fiscal pour la recherche vous êtes
peut-être allé un peu loin monsieur le
président mais je fus assez vous
oui parce que le paradis fiscal je
ferais générique c'est un paradis fiscal
pour la bonne cause indifférence
d'autres paradis fiscaux
donc on va passer une première série de
questions alors qu'ils souhaitent madame
madame lienemann et ensuite selon
facebook et monsieur bon je vous en prie
allez-y mais ce gallois moi je
j'apprécie beaucoup ce que vous avez dit
notamment dans votre rapport sur le hors
coûts et puisque vous avez été vous même
à une responsabilité majeure avec le
haut-commissariat l'industrie c'est ça
je crois le nom à l'investissement
pardon
est-ce que vous avez le sentiment que la
france dans leurs coûts a
maintenant fait un effort substantiel
qui devrait s qui a pas sur ce champ là
encore beaucoup à faire
et ça m'amène à la deuxième question
c'est qu'on avait eu ce débat sur les
mesures générales le coup électrochoc
par rapport à la et je préfère votre
présentation sur un booster pour
restaurer des marges plutôt qu'une
théorie générale de la baisse des coûts
du travail
néanmoins est ce que il y aurait pas eu
vous mais j'avais bien senti une
sensibilité et que vous essayez de
convaincre
justement ce qui me préoccupe c'est que
est ce que les 35 milliards qu'on a mis
dans le cic eu enfin de maintenance et
c'est plus un logement est-ce qu'ils
auraient pas été plus opportun parce
qu'on regarde que la part industrie est
quand même assez faiblement je parle pas
que de l'industrie pure je pense de
services à l'industrie même si on peut
dire qu un balayeur d'une entreprise de
balayage services à l'industrie mais
enfin ces impacts quand même modérément
les coûts est ce que il y aurait pas eu
plus d'intérêt à mettre cet argent sur
des stratégies de filières
d'accompagnement de stratégie de filière
en mutation d'investissement et en
particulier sur les plans de
robotisation du pays parce qu'en plus le
fait qu'on cible aux aides sur des
catégories salariales plutôt en bas
finalement n'est pas tellement
incitatif à faire l'arbitrage
robotisation modernisation plutôt que
salaire est en tout cas investissements
donc là vous ai déjà dit les
amortissements accélérés
mais ce qu'il ya d'autres formes dead
qui aurait par exemple le mettre de
l'argent la bpi la bpi nous indique
finalement pour les prêts comment on
appelle ça les très longue durée à
faible rendement là comment il s'appelle
deçà des prêts et nous en donner un nom
technique pour des prêts
de développement
un peu solide dans la durée et coin gpus
un nom il semble qu'il manque de crédit
pour ce type de prêt est ce qu'il
n'aurait pas été plus utile de
transférer une partie des sommes de la
bpi est ce que c'est pas là qu'il
faudrait mettre des aides
complémentaires et je termine
sur l'expérience qu'a fait obama des
manufacturiers alors le plan américain
de
de relance de l'industrie manufacturière
et il est quand même fondé sur toute une
série d'activités eux ils arrivent à
différencier leurs aides fiscales et
sociales en fonction des secteurs
industriels or une des thèses en france
et on peut pas parce que il ya de la
concurrence on n'a pas le droit de faire
des haines mais ne pourrions nous pas
avoir des aides sélectives et de ce
point de vue le crédit impôt recherche
quand même une grande sélectivité
industriel mc les banques et c est ce
qui aurait pas la possibilité d'avoir
pour une partie des aides fiscales ou
des maudits des allégements de
cotisations
une des contreparties qu'ils soient
adossées à des contrats de filières à
des conventions de filière c'est à dire
si je puis dire avoir une règle générale
c'est que si on signe une convention de
développement
industriel ou à ce moment là des
allègements de charges ils sont
conditionnés ce qui à ce moment-là
permet quand même de cibler là où on
veut atteindre des objectifs en commun
deuxième chose qui a dans le plan
américain
c'est quand même pas mal de
protectionnisme ils ont une commission
nationale de vérification des normes des
autres est-ce qu'on est assez vigilant
s'agissant de l'invasion de certains
produits en france et 3
ils font des choses que je trouve
intéressant qui sont des ce qu'ils
appellent les centres d'innovation
manufacturière qui c'est toute la thèse
du vivier du vivier de compétences est
ce que vous pensez qu'il ya en france un
problème de vivier de compétences et en
particulier pour redonner goût à des
techniciens des ingénieurs etc ils font
descendre de vivier de compétences vous
avez vu sans doute celui de l'ohio sur
le 3d et tout ça je trouve que c'est une
façon de mobiliser l'opinion autour de
plans de filières assez intelligente
donc en tout cas sur leurs coûts parce
qu'on se focalise beaucoup mais on a
l'air de penser qu'il ya pas d'autres
moyens et ses fautes de ses autres
moyens que le problème du coût du
travail apparaît comme un des éléments
sur lequel la puissance publique peut
agir donc je me permettais de vous
interroger sur ce site c'est tout
alors peut-être qu'on ne va prendre que
deux questions parce que les questions
de madame manon était assez nombreuse
peut-être celle de monsieur montesquiou
et ensuite on fera une autre série
6 music président
me pose un problème parce que je n'ai
pas su déceler
de divergence
vos affirmations et mes convictions
c'est uniquement dû à l'origine commune
du sud ouest où un amour partagé du
rugby mon extrême en extrapolant vos
propos est ce qu'il n'ya pas une
dramatique erreur de stratégie
et de la part de l'industrie française
et de la part de nos dirigeants sur
beaucoup trop d'années et est ce que on
a été est-ce qu'on n'est pas à la traîne
d'autres pays comme l'allemagne souvent
cité bien sûr mais aussi l'italie mais
aussi la corée du sud mais aussi de
japon mais aussi l'inde
bangalore l'été dernier dans le meilleur
exemple est peut-être la chine qui je
crois où commencent à produire des
produits de grande qualité est-ce que
l'inversion de cette stratégie
et qu'on est forcément concevoir mais
forcément aussi sur une longue durée ça
veut pas se faire en trois ans
dix ans peut-être est-ce que l'état
n'aggravent pas cet état de fait en
privilégiant comme vous l'avez souligné
les bas salaires est ce qu'il ne faut
pas au contraire viser une très haute
qualité par des très hauts salaires est
une chose qui n'a pas été si c'est tout
à l'heure on a inventé un peu le point
des charges est ce que le fait que les
charges proportionnelles au salaire
ne contribue pas
aussi à
faire cette modération qui fait de lui
aujourd'hui avec la mobilité qui peut
exister au niveau international
et
l'élection peut qu être qualificative
les gens les plus qualifiés ne vont-ils
pas chercher bonne fortune ailleurs vont
aborder un peu le problème des
investissements la taxe à 115% un
message dramatique qui va aussi dans le
même sens
même si c'est un sujet haute et ce sera
dieu ça se traduit par une baisse
abyssale des investissements étrangers
en france est-ce que tout ne
contribue-t-il pas aujourd'hui à
abaisser le niveau de la production un
niveau où on n'est pas lui qu'on peut
pas être compétitif parce que c'est
surtout le cookie et qui intervient
auprès de compétitif élevé que les dpi
avec des salaires à 200 ou 300 euros
donc
est-ce qu'il faut pas réviser totalement
cette politique industrielle est aussi
inciter les industriels à choisir
d'autres créneaux
ces présidentielles et bien répondre je
ferai juste deux petites remarques
peut-être très bref sur ce qu'a dit
madame lienemann pour alimenter d un peu
le débat en ce qui concerne les aides
sur les filières on se souvient de
sinistre mémoire quand même des aides
sur les charges sociales type a cuit
texte où les entreprises on est déjà
obligé de rembourser enfin exterran
oui mais j'étais dans une entreprise cas
durant
oui mais mais j'étais dans une
entreprise qui allait rembourser à
l'époque c'était assez assez douloureux
et simplement quelque chose qu'on n'a
peut-être pas évoquer qui est cher à
madame la rapporteure on parle souvent
l'investissement
donc dans en termes de compétitivité et
l'investissement matériel mais il ya eu
il ya aussi l'investissement humain en
termes de formation qu'on n'a peut-être
pas qui est qui est intéressant
bon
c'est très vaste
non madame la sénatrice
le
leur coup vous avez vous que leurs
couilles l'action du commissaire général
à l'investissement
effectivement
c'était notre travail c'est le travail
de mon successeur le choix de m
je pense que
bon j'avais été au début un peu
sceptique lorsque avait été lancé le
grand emprunt je me dis un pays qui est
déjà très endetté qui lance un grand
emprunt pour financer l'innovation la
recherche et c est ce que est ce que
c'est vraiment approprié j'ai changé
d'avis peut-être d'ailleurs parce que
j'ai bénéficié du concours et
être honnête mais j'ai changé d'avis
parce que je crois que empreintes et
surtout dans les conditions actuelles
pour financer l'avenir ça a du sens
parce que même du point de vue financier
le taux de retour pour la collectivité
de ces investissements a de très bonnes
chances d'être supérieurs aux taux
d'intérêt qui sera payée et donc je
pense qu emprunter pour financer
l'avenir ça a du sens ça plus de sens
que d'emprunter pour financer les
salaires des fonctionnaires bon
mais c'est bon donc
je suis et en plus ce travail en ayant
travaillé deux ans dans ce commissariat
de manière que j'ai trouvé absolument
passionnante je ne m'attendais pas à
trouver autant de d'intérêt et de
plaisir à ce job que j'ai quitté avec
beaucoup de nostalgie pas de regret
parce qu'il faudra voir même nostalgie
jeu
je crois qu'il le ca va dans la bonne
direction dès lors qu'on sera capable de
maintenir le cap qui est de financer
l'avenir et de pas se substituer au
budget de l'état
et ça c'est la grande difficulté en
période d'économies budgétaires chaque
ministère qui est à
faqir étranglé c'est peut-être exercice
mais enfin qui qui a des difficultés
vient voir le commissariat pour demander
des crédits en substitution de ces
propos crédits budgétaires qu'il n'a pas
donc je pense que ça ne doit pas être le
cas il faut privilégier la recherche
l'innovation l'accélération du passage
de la recherche à l'innovation
le
travail est interdisciplinaire des
centres de recherche ce travail en
commun un partenariat entre les centres
de recherche et l'industrie entre les
grandes entreprises et les petites
industries c'est tout ce que fait le
commissariat et je pense que ça va dans
le bon sens je le disais notre objectif
c'est d'accroître le niveau de la
croissance potentielle du pays et
accroître la croissance potentielle en
allant vers le haut pas pas en
prodiguant médicale espagnole où on
baisse les coûts ou on fait de la
dévaluation sociales fiscales et de tous
ordres pour
gagner de la compétitivité je pense que
la france a capacité par sa base de
technique par sont la base de recherches
de trouver la compétitivité par le haut
dans encore une fois dans la montée en
gamme c'est ce que
vise le comice âge investissements et je
trouve que globalement il accomplit bien
sa tâche c'est qu'on commence à voir le
premier effet problème c'est que c'est
une affaire de dix ans je vous disais jg
c'est une affaire de dix ans et on ose à
peine le dire mais on a perdu cette
compétitivité en 10 15 ans va là on
pourra le retrouver en deux ans je
rappelle que l'allemagne le plan
l'agenda 2010 de schröder ses 10 ans
avec trois majorités politiques
différentes et 2 chancelier de bords
opposés qui ont mené exactement la même
politique
ça vous donne une cohérence une
persévérance dans l'action
qui
est à mon avis indispensable
alors ensuite vous avez évoqué
on aurait pu faire mieux que les 30
milliards c'est la question qu'on se
pose chaque fois
je suis
je crois qu'il était il est important de
faire les deux d'avoir des politiques
qui s'adresse un certain nombre de
filières je reviendrai là dessus parce
que il faut le faire avec doigté
et en même temps je pense qu'il le
fallait
faire un
créer
un événement
et il je souhaitais moi qui porte les
allocations familiales parce que
j'estimais encore une fois que ce sont
des dépenses qui relève de la solidarité
nationale donc plus de la fiscalité
même si je sais qu'il ya un vaste débat
sur le sujet mais je vous ai expliqué
mes raisons et je pensais que c'était
quelque chose qui pouvait
recréer de la confiance
nous verrons si c'est le cas
la bpi
alors avec les 30 milliards doter la bpi
moi je trouve que la baby a fait plutôt
un bon démarrage
c'est un outil qui assez curieusement
d'ailleurs ne suscite aucun débat
idéologique
jeu je constate que tout le monde est à
peu près convaincu que cet instrument
manquer surtout surtout avec un secteur
bancaire qui est maintenant corsetée par
des règles de prudentielles qui
l'empêchent de financer assez largement
aussi largement qu'il pourrait le
souhaiter l'industrie
les bâle iii c'est pareil d'ailleurs
pour les compagnies d'assurances avec
soul ainsi 2 qui
qui les empêche de
d'intervenir massivement en fonds
propres sur
pour les fonds propres des entreprises
donc je crois que c'est un instrument
utile
je pense qu'ils doivent démontrer que
ceux d'il ya une montée en régime on
peut pas tout leur donner il faut il
faut assurer une montée en régime de la
bpi elle se met en place elle a même pas
un an d'existence je rappelle qu'elle
date du 12 juillet 2013
et donc les elle est récente il faut
qu'elles qu'elles créent ce qu elle ce
qu'elle crée son savoir faire qu'elle
accumule de l'expérience et je pense
qu'il faut organiser sa montée en régime
sachant qu'on peut elle peut pas aller
très loin parce que d'abord c'est une
banque les sourires réglementation
bancaire et deuxièmement il faut faire
attention qu'elle est sous dans l'oeil
du coup dans le collimateur de la
direction de la concurrence
de bruxelles 1 donc il faut donc aller
avait quand même très elle peut
elle a des contraintes dans ce qu'elle
peut faire
vous avez évoqué la relance de
l'industrie manufacturière ceci étant
dit les indices tendent à venir d'autres
la bpi pour lui permettre d'intervenir
justement en fonds propres dans les
entreprises de faire des prêts verts il
ya un certain nombre de
d'éléments de la politique de la bpi qui
sont alimentés par le commissariat et
d'ailleurs nous avions un petit débat
avec le baby pour savoir comment t'est
assurer la gouvernance de ces
financements nous souhaitions une
gouvernance partagée que la bpi ne
considère pas que cet argent lui
appartenait enfin c'est un autre sujet
relance de l'industrie manufacturière
moi j'ai trouvé
intéressante l'initiative de d'arnaud
montebourg des 34 plan industriel bon je
lui ai dit je trouve que 34 ça fait
beaucoup
mais c'est très difficile parce que si
vous oubliez un secteur ce secteur ce
secteur hurle si vous l'oubliez
pardon
oui il a indiqué comme il le comme vous
le dites je peux le reprendre il indiqué
que certaines l'aient pas jusqu'au bout
et que donc il y aura un effet darwinia
darwinia de doses sur ses plans mais le
fait de confier ses plans à des à des
industriels pour les piloter est une
bonne idée
j'ai trouvé que certains d'entre eux
pouvaient créer une certaine dynamique
d'autant plus qu'ils étaient assis sur
des travaux du conseil national de
l'industrie et le problème ça va être le
financement ce financement va être
assurée par les éditions d'avenir on pas
se faire d'illusions c'est eux qui vont
c'est d'ailleurs une des raisons je
pense qui a conduit monsieur montebourg
a souhaité que le comice âge
investissements l'histoire attaché
ce qu'ils ne peuvent pas manqué de créer
prolin et d'autres ministres mais il
paraît que france tout ceci est en voie
de solution je m'en réjouis
sur le protectionnisme
je je
je n'aime pas cette expression je le dis
franchement
je préfère réciprocité je préfère qu'on
considère que parce que l'expression
protectionnisme est maintenant dépassée
quand on voit ce que ce qu'est ce que ce
qu'est une chaîne de production
les produits que nous produisons en
france sont constitués de parts de
d'éléments qui viennent du monde entier
et une partie de ce que nous produisons
en france va dans des produits qu'ils
sont
vendu dans le val éo valeo faurecia
travaille d'abord pour l'industrie
allemande
il exporte à travers les voitures
allemandes donc je crois qu'il faut se
méfier de des effets que corée
le protectionnisme en revanche ce que
vous dites sur les normes ce que vous
dites sur des standards de sécurité de
qualité
ce que vous dites sur le respect d'un
certain nombre de règles évidentes de
droit du travail travail des enfants etc
tout ça c'est la réciprocité l'ouverture
des marchés publics
peut-on admettre de
voir nos marchés publics ouverts à des
entreprises qui n'ouvre pas les leurs
avait à des pays qui n'ouvre des
entreprises de pays qui n'ouvre pas les
leurs ou qui les ouvrent mal
je pense que cette question de
réciprocité est vraiment une question
sérieuse et peut-être que nous brûlions
poussé à niveau de bruxelles un peu plus
cette notion même si la france le fait
et si bruxelles du bout des lèvres
reconnaît la réciprocité mais ne peut
pas s'engager dans cette voie parce que
elle considère que c'est l'antichambre
du dih protectionnistes mais moi je
pense que réciprocité entre la
différenciation des secteurs vous l'avez
dit
vous même madame la sénatrice
le
il faut il faut le faire avec l'habileté
il faut le faire sans contrevenir aux
règles de bruxelles et la difficulté du
genre de l'exercice vous ne pouvez pas
décider d'un allègement fiscal qui ne
concerne que l'industrie par exemple pas
possible ah c'est pas possible
donc vous pouvez intervenir en revanche
en amont sur la recherche la wii on peut
intervenir c'est ce qu'on appelle le pré
compétitif
les centres d'innovation
manufacturière et bien ça existe en
france ça s'appelle les
ça s'appelle les centres techniques ou
ça s'appelle les carnot l'institut
carnot
le cetim par exemple l'industrie
mécanique vous avez vous avez ce genre
de choses qui sont de l'exemple pour
nous et prisches dans les instituts
fraunhofer en allemagne nous avons des
calques et les aspirants de fer en
allemagne et je pense maintenant que les
carnot ont pris une véritable densité
n'ont pas l'expérience des frères ofer
ils n'ont pas le tissu de relations avec
les entreprises qu'on les fera 9 heures
mais je pense que là nous avons
commençons maintenant avoir l'outil qui
devrait au fur et à mesure acquérir
justement cette intimité avec le tissu
industriel est en tout cas c'est en ce
sens qu'il faut le qu'il faut le pousser
monsieur de montesquiou
je suis pas loin d'être d'accord avec
vous
je pense que à force de pratiquer bessat
mais
à force de pratiquer les
exonérations sur les bas salaires parce
que on considère que le smic étant élevé
on compense à en réduisant les charges
sur les bas salaires
c'est ça ça nous conduit à
avantager des industries de manoeuvre
qui sont pas obligatoirement d'ailleurs
les industries qui exportent parce que
ce sont souvent c'est comme ça qu'on
fait vivre les grandes surfaces quand
même
donc je ne suis pas la pause mais l'état
je pense est capable l'argent des
docks
oui d'abord ces entreprises mais en plus
la poste et traverse une période
traverse une période difficile difficile
difficile
la postant une course difficile et je
pense que
cette aide n'est pas absolument
sans sans utilité mais ceci étant dit je
trouve qu'à force davantage et les bas
salaires on a on a beaucoup de bas
salaires
on a beaucoup de bas salaires et je
pense qu'il faut trouver un meilleur
équilibre vous avez cité
des séries de pays
que que je pourrai reprendre
l'allemagne un système différent du
nôtre sur le plan social c'est à dire
que les charges sociales sont plafonnés
un certain niveau de salaire et le reste
c'est l'assurance privée qui n'est
d'ailleurs jamais pris en compte
lorsqu'on calcule le coût global pour le
salarié de son affaire mais bon
ça remet en cause un des principes de
notre
de la sécurité sociale française qui la
solidarité entre les français quand même
hein c'est assez lourd comme décision ne
pas faire payer les très hauts salaires
pour la solidarité avec les plus bas
salaires pour la contrepartie quand même
du système français de sécurité sociale
c'est que les inégalités augmentent
moins qu'ailleurs et que nous avons un
taux de pauvreté inférieur à celui de
l'allemagne quand même pas totalement
négligeable même si nous traversons des
périodes difficiles
à c'est une pauvreté qui est partagée
comme la nôtre c'est une pauvreté qui
est partagé entre les différentes mais
ce sont des gens qui vivent en allemagne
situation de pauvreté
bon sur donc
moi je jeu pour revenir à votre question
je pense que votre question est valide
est ce que est ce que la force de faire
des exonérations sur les bas salaires on
avantage pas les bas salaires par
rapport par rapport aux salaires qui
apporte qui à forte valeur ajoutée je ne
dis pas que les autres dans l'est pas
mais dans la proportionnelle ce concert
on maintient au maintien mais vous avez
raison maintien bas niveaux de
qualification donne aucun encouragement
à la formation professionnelle vous
jeunes et pauvres je n'ai pas encore je
n'ai pas encore évoqué la formation
professionnelle mais effectivement une
formation professionnelle qui ne se
traduirait pas dans les entreprises par
la possibilité de trouver des carrières
qui monte pour les gens pourquoi voulez
vous qu'ils se forment si c'est pour
rester au niveau où ils sont et donc je
pense que il ya il ya une certaine
perversité à ce système
ceci étant dit j'en parle d'autant plus
que je ne suis pas au gouvernement et
que je n'ai pas les statistiques du
chômage qui tombent tous les mois parce
que quand vous avez saisies chômage qui
tombent tous les mois et que vous voyez
que sa situation ne s'améliore pas aussi
pas aussi vite que vous le souhaiteriez
vous avez envie de donner un petit coup
de pouce pour que ça accélère et le
moyen de donner le petit coup de pouce
pour qu'il accélère ses des exonérations
sur les bas salaires c'est ce que répond
est monsieur 7
pardon oui mais
mais je sais que je constate avec une
certaine surprise mais je m'en réjouis
parce que celle du précédent
je crois que non mais notre audition je
veux dire touche à sa fin et je crois
que nous avons encore une question au
moins donc je pars avec un objet fini
bien monsieur dowd signé merci monsieur
le président donnait la parole
c'est un plaisir monsieur nous entendre
parler de la compétitivité
une remarque très vite sur la poste
beaucoup de ces activités sont en
concurrence avec des entreprises privées
dans paris circulent des camions où il
est indiqué port de lettres de goût de
colis pour particuliers et privé mais
c'est pas le sujet de la question
j'étais hier avec des représentants
français et allemands d'une grande
entreprise de chimie allemande qui a des
usines en france et qui intervient en
phytosanitaires pharmacie et polymères
vous pouvez identifier lorsqu'il a été
demandé à ses responsables quels sont
les atouts en france 2 mots le premier
les cerveaux le deuxième le crédit impôt
recherche
donc ça vient à l'appui dit ce qui a été
dit avant c'est pour ça que je le sais
pour ça que je le souligne alors ensuite
lorsqu'il leur a été posée la question
des handicaps sont cités plus
l'instabilité fiscale que le coût du
travail ensuite et si tu es également
une application venir et les des normes
européennes dans notre pays qui est un
frein à l'activité en particulier je dis
donc en matière d'environnement et puis
ensuite est également citée comme
handicap
une inscription qui serait beaucoup trop
forte dans
l'esprit français du principe de
précaution qui fait que le moindre
incident où le moindre doute génère
immédiatement des peurs des craintes des
polémiques et quelquefois d'ailleurs
génèrent de nouveaux textes législatifs
alors est ce que monsieur gallois il y a
dans les mentalités françaises ainsi
réellement un frein à l'innovation à la
recherche
est-ce que ce ressenti tels que je viens
de le rappeler est fondé à votre avis je
pense que les éléments que vous avez
donné je ne peux qu'abonder dans ce sens
l'instabilité fiscale et
l'imprévisibilité fiscale et puis le
fait qu'on ait quand même inventé
l'import de trois actifs
tout ça c'est je pense extrêmement
déstabilisant pour les entreprises elles
ont besoin d'avoir un peu
d'horizon des de savoir ce qui va là
même si c'est pas très agréable
je pense que nous avons dans ce domaine
un très gros efforts à faire j'avais
proposé qu' un certain nombre de mesures
fiscales qui soit
gelée c'est à dire qu'on ne puisse pas
bougé ça a été repris dans le pacte de
compétitivité du gouvernement
je souhaite que l'on puisse s'étendre
autant que possible cette règle de
stabilité fiscale de règles fiscales
sociales environnementales alors j'en
viens à l'environnement c'est à dire
l'application et les des normes
européennes au principe de précaution
et j'allais dire que je vous vous vous
me poussez dans tellement dense qu'ils
me dans le sens où j'ai envie d'aller
que j'ai peur de trébucher
jeu j'estime que le principe de
précaution le principal des risques
c'est d'un pas en prendre
paske appartement on prendra plus de
risques là c'est le déclin donc je pense
qu'il faut que nous soyons capables de
prendre des risques en les mesurant en
les évaluant en débattant mais prendre
des risques elle a la vie est faite
comme ça est ce que vous imaginez
pasteur n'a pas pris de risques je joue
ici inoculer le vaccin de la rage et
marie curie rhin est morte la mer
s'est pas
non et d'ailleurs je jacques attali dit
que l'invention quelques plus de monde
au 20e siècle c'est l'électricité quand
même hein donc il faut il faut que nous
soyons capables de
2,2 de mesurer ce que ce principe de
précaution peut avoir de
dangereux et qu'on l'a mis dans la
constitution est regrettable je dois
dire que les allemands sont pas loin
d'être comme nous un sur le principe de
précaution
mais quand je vois que
sûr
je pars je veux pas paraître plus plus
plus méchant que je ne suis mais si je
prends nanotechnologies biotechnologies
ogm gaz de schiste nucléaire etc autant
de sujets dont on n'aura plus droit de
parler je trouve que ça fait beaucoup
et certainement il ya d'excellentes
raisons mais à force de se bloquer
toutes les avenues je ne sais pas où
vers où on peut avancer et
d'applications et les des normes
européennes on nous dit qu'on est plus
élevé que les autres et que en matière
environnementale en particulier nous
allons plus vite et plus fort que les
autres je
l'entend beaucoup dire de la part des
industriels je vous donnerai seulement
un exemple une entreprise qui s'appelle
paprec qui est assez connu dans le
recyclage le patron d'hp après que quand
je faisais mon rapport m'a dit sur les
huit prévenus à 2012 quarante et une
modification de la réglementation sur
les déchets il m'a dit j'ai trois
personnes qui ne font que ça dans mon
entreprise c'est examiner l'évolution de
la réglementation ça c'est possible
l'entreprise de l'importance de paprec
c'est pas possible pour beaucoup
d'autres entreprises qui n'ont pas la
taille suffisante pour cela et je pense
que nous devons veiller à cela c'est
pour ça que je suis j'avais indiqué
j'intervenais là dessus que le choc de
simplification c'est une affaire
politique majeure qui ne peut être prise
en charge qu'au plus haut niveau de
l'état c'est le seul moyen d'y arriver
sinon l'administration française dont je
suis issue et que j'aime beaucoup c'est
une machine à produire des règlements
formidable et donc elle va
elle va en produire
oui mais il y en a beaucoup trop
simplement c'est alors madame leur
apportera encore une question très brève
et vous lui ferez une réponse très brève
mais sur très brève
simplement pour faire une remarque ce
que vous venez de dire sur la norme je
pense qu'on pourrait ajouter aussi là
maintenant qui va encore en rajouter
sans aucune efficacité les spawns le
dispositif sur la pénibilité non pas que
je sois contre la prise en compte de la
moby la pénibilité vous le savez bien
donner ce qu'on a mis en place alors là
c'est terrible c'est vraiment et je vais
c'est pour l'anecdote je pense qu'on a
une très grande capacité à créer des
usines gaz très très grande capacité et
un pêcheur
moi je voulais revenir sur
sur le petit débat qu'on a eue sur le
fait que en fait les l'utilisation des
exonérations sur les bas salaires
finalement ça devient une forme de
facilité même si
mais moi je conteste ce contexte je
conteste aussi ça parce que bon il a
deux sur les bas salaires il ya il ya
deux objectifs c'est la courbe du
chômage est aussi amené les jeunes non
qualifiés qui sortent du dispositif a
pour qui accède enfin à l'emploi et donc
d'abord l'efficacité des sur les bas
salaires allaient contester puisque le
rendement est très faible et vous ne
croyez pas que plutôt que d'utiliser
cet argent public sur cette faible
efficacité il n'y a pas vraiment un plan
massif de formation
intégrateurs à mettre en place consacré
beaucoup plus d'argent et de manière
beaucoup plus active
pour justement sortir de cette impasse
et nous intéresser tous ces jeunes qui
sont sans formation moi j'ai souvenir
moi je viens d'une la région du nord pas
de calais avec ses grandes entreprises
qui vont évidemment c'est dans une
période faste puis c'était les trente
glorieuses intégrer les jeunes dans des
centres de formation à l'intérieur des
usines dans les cales y passer leur
diplôme sur les où il était rémunéré qui
avait quand même ainsi un succès qui
intègre et justement tous ces jeunes
issus du monde ouvrier et qui trouvait
tout à fait leur place dans la société
je pense que cet exemple il faut or
aujourd'hui l'apprentissage en france
c'est quand même pas terrible j'irai
même gérer pas jusqu'à dire que c'est un
échec mais j'ai en tête les remarques
qui vient qui ont été faites récemment
par un célèbre inspecteur du travail que
tout le monde connaît qui est gérard
filoche qui expliquait que nous conte
contrairement à l'allemagne nous nous
conservions très très peur assurent 70%
il n'en restait que 40 % parce que les
entreprises ne savait pas faire quel
d'abord c'était trop faiblement
rémunérés que la plupart du temps elle
avait du mal à ne pas s'imaginer que
c'était une main d'oeuvre à bas prix et
vous avez l'âme je viens de donner une
interview jean nouvel sur
l'apprentissage je pense que qui est un
cri d'alarmé l'apprentissage a baissé de
et la formation est là et il les
contrats de professionnalisation ont
baissé de 8% en 2013 et le début de
l'année les trois premiers mois sont
très mauvais encore en baisse par
rapport à 2013 alors que l'objectif
était passé de 415 à 500000 je constate
que seulement 12 % des entreprises de
plus de 250 salariés respectent
l'obligation
le nombre d'apprentis
qui est prévu légale et elle préfère
payer les les pas les amants de le coup
au
haut niveau des branches plutôt que de
le faire elle même c'est à dire que de
ce côté là il ya il ya une déficience
combien déficiences du côté de
l'éducation nationale et questionne le
promeneur peut leur apprentissage plus
tellement pour des raisons idéologiques
qui en a encore un peu mais de moins en
moins parce que les syndicats de
salariés eux ont viré leur cuti
maintenant défendre d'apprentissage pour
façon vous savez aux cliniques de
paternalisme et c est maintenant
l'apprentissage et est supporté et
soutenue et le deuxièmement c'est que
l'apprentissage apparaît d'une certaine
manière comme concurrent des lycées
professionnels
or le le le il ya une inquiétude en
lycée professionnel puisque le nombre
d'élèves dans les six prochaines baisses
en france donc
il apparaît une sorte de concurrence
troisièmement je trouve que
on a pas
on n'a jamais manifesté sur l'éducation
sur l'apprentissage une ambition qui
aurait conduit un programme national moi
j'appelle de mes voeux un programme
national ambitieux sur l'apprentissage
c'est absolument indispensable et qui
regarde qui comment l'éducation
nationale les entreprises peuvent être
plus actives dans ce domaine quels
financements et comment on prend en
compte le problème des jeunes apprentis
comment voulez vous qu'un jeune de 16 à
17 ans trouve tout seul son sens son
stage c'est pas possible sauf s'il un
réseau familial il n'ya que ça ils
peuvent pas se loger parce que le
il n'y a pas de ils peuvent pas se payer
un logement éloigné du logement familial
il les frais de transport toutes ces
questions qui sont extrêmement précises
mérite d'être regardée de 2,2 très près
et je pense que encore une fois c'est un
sujet absolument majeur je partage votre
avis un homme de messine
c'est de l'argent bien utilisé pour
lutter contre le chômage et pour
permettre une meilleure adéquation de
l'offre et de la demande de travail
que que l'apprentissage je pense que en
plus ça fait monter tout le monde et il
faut que je le disais l'apprentissage
c'est pas la roue de secours du système
éducatif ça doit être une des deux
routes devant il ya un enseignement
général et ya l'apprentissage c'est ce
qui se passe en allemagne je remercie
monsieur le président ce sera donc votre
conclusion et nous vous remercions pour
votre parole qui est toujours paroles
très fortes en matière de compétitivité
merci encore
voilà pour l'audition de louis gallois
je vous propose tout de suite de suivre
une autre audition celle d'henri yeux
sterdyniak le directeur du département
économie de la mondialisation alors fc
eux et on se retrouve tout de suite
après pour ce qui concerne l'effet sur
l'emploi des allègements de cotisations
sociales
les évaluations de love se
sont plutôt situés on va dire dans la
fourchette basse en raison notamment des
effets macroéconomiques du financement
de cet instrument et dans ces conditions
quel instrument seriez vous amener à
privilégier pour l'emploi et par
ailleurs des allégements de cotisations
et des mécanismes de compensation qui en
résultent pose la question de
l'évolution du mode de financement de la
protection sociale et au fil des mesures
que nous avons des facto aux mises en
place
un barème de cotisations sociales
progressif et estimez vous que les
cotisations sont de votre point de vue
le meilleur outil de redistribution
et si nous devons faire évaluer évoluer
par dont l'assiette du financement de la
protection sociale
quelles sont les mesures susceptibles de
concilier équité d'une part et
efficacité économique de l'autre
quelques petites questions qui
pourraient servir à votre propos
liminaires et ensuite
un homme la rapporteure vous soumettra
la question si j'ose dire et puis nos
collègues donc sans plus tarder je vous
laisse donc la parole monsieur directeur
vous savez tous qu'en 2007 la france
avatar atteint un taux de chômage de 7%
on est aujourd'hui à 10 5%
aucun mystère sur les causes de cette
forte hausse du taux de chômage elle
résulte avant tout d'un de la crise
économique de la crise du
du capitalisme mondialisé qui a provoqué
qui a implosé en 2007
ce qui caractérise
la période qu'on a connus avant 2007
c'est la concurrence commerciale les
délocalisations qui font que
les entreprises ont tendance à aller
tout à fait naturellement aller chercher
des travailleurs les moins chers
possibles ça fait pression sur le coût
du travail dans les pays développés est
donc dans de nombreux pays la part du
travail diminue au profit de la part de
capital la france a heureusement été un
peu épargné par ailleurs donc
7,7 des formations se traduit par un
déficit de demande qui est comblé soit
par les déficits publics soit par la
montée de l'endettement du secteur privé
des ménages des entreprises
et naturellement parce qu'on l'a vu en
2007 c'est que à cette montée de
l'endettement a des limites à un moment
donné les agents sont trop endettés non
à la crise de subprimes on à la crise
des
de la dette des pays
du sud 2
de la zone euro et puis on a le problème
que on a des masses énormes de capitaux
qui sont disponibles qui cherchent une
rentabilité maximale et tout ça ça
provoque une forte instabilité
économique donc on est dans ce contexte
où il est très difficile de la france
fasse quelque chose à elles seules il
serait souhaitable
que l'europe agisse mais bon jusqu'à
présent l'europe n'a pas la volonté
politique d'agir et donc on est contre à
utiliser des méthodes qui sont
s'attaque pas
fondamentalement au coeur du problème il
est évident
que la tentation c'est celle-là
dévaluation fiscale c'est-à-dire de dire
dans tous les pays on va réduire
puisqu'on puisqu'on est dans la zone
euro on peut plus dévaluer
donc on va réduire les salaires si on
peut pas réduire les salaires on va
réduire les cotisations sociales
employeurs et en contrepartie
va réduire la protection sociale les
dépenses publiques de manière à gagner
en compétitivité
ce qui bien sûr est très sympathique
lorsqu'on le fait une zone et man
c'est ce que l'allemagne a fait et c'est
la catastrophe quand tout le monde le
fait c'est sympathique comme quand
effectivement on peut compenser sa part
une hausse du déficit public ce que
l'allemagne a fait ce que nous on peut
plus faire et même dans le cas de
l'allemagne sa stratégie de 2000 à 2005
s'est traduit par une croissance
extrêmement faible
et donc la stratégie
réduction des cotisations sociales
employeurs à des effets médiocre quand
un seul pays il entreprend et des effets
catastrophiques en si elle est un
entrepris à l'ensemble de la de la zone
euro
ensuite ya un petit problème technique
ou effectivement là certains économistes
disent oui vous avez raison mais il ya
un mirail à une solution miracle inquiet
de concentrer les réductions de
cotisations sociales employeurs sur les
bas salaires sont les très bas salaires
sur le niveau du smig et là on obtient
une élasticité fabuleuse du de l'emploi
au coût du travail donc on peut créer
massivement des emplois non qualifiés
ce qui permet de résoudre en partie le
problème du chômage
et donc à cette stratégie a été mise en
oeuvre de façon massive en france
soutenue par tous les grands est connu
que tous les économistes français
spécialiste du marché du travail
et ils ont réussi jusqu'à présent à
persuader le gouvernement qu'il faut
poursuivre 7,7 dans cette direction
d'accor regarde
les travaux empiriques
tout dépend d'abord de ce qu'on appelle
l'élasticité du travail à son cou
qui est très difficile à estimer
s'ils insistaient du travail est
supérieure à 1
grosso modo on peut dire
ça vaut le coup parce que quand on donne
100 entreprises là et qu
il augmente la masse salariale d'un
chiffre supérieur à 100
donc c'est intéressant qu'on a des
élasticités qui sont inférieures à la
mesure est nuisible parce que finalement
autant creed directement des emplois
plutôt que subventionner les entreprises
vous créer des emplois à bas salaires
lorsque montrent les estimations dans
les estimations empirique sont
extrêmement fragiles on s'appuie
généralement sur des vieux travaux
américains qui portaient sur l'industrie
et qu'on généralise au service et donc
il y avait un consensus qui s'établit de
manière administrative pour dire
l'élasticité au niveau du smic c'est 08
et puis ensuite sa baisse jusqu'à 0,2
pour les salaires les plus élevés et
donc avec ça on obtient un résultat
qu'on nenê si c'était moyenne de 0,6
donc le coût d'un emploi créé en
réduisant les cotisations par des
méthodes comme les exonérations bassal r
c'est de l'ordre de 34 mille euros par
emploi créé alors qu'un emploi public au
smic c'est de l'ordre de 24 mille et
donc on and
on a des mesures qui sont peu efficaces
ensuite on se pose la question quelle
est cette élasticité que l'on mesure et
là c'est extrêmement contestable parce
que effectivement on peut avoir une
mesure qui permet de créer beaucoup de
d'emploi bas salaires
notre parti le risque c'est que ont
détruit des emplois mieux qualifier
peut-être - nice pose la question c'est
quand même ennuyeux de
d'amener vers le bas notre
notre masse salariale il est tout à fait
évident que
lorsque on fait des exonérations
importante au niveau du smic on va
favoriser les entreprises qui utilisent
une main-d'oeuvre précaires mal payés
à mi temps
et au détriment d'entreprises qui ont
une main d'oeuvre
stable avec des possibilités d'évolution
et donc c'est une stratégie c'est une
stratégie risquée
et qui correspond pas aux besoins de la
france qui sont de montée en gamme et de
trouver des emplois pour des salariés
qui sont des jeunes qui sont de mieux en
mieux de mieux en mieux formés
effectivement
le taux de chômage
des diplômés est nettement plus faible
que celui des non diplômés mais c'est
pas du tout une caractéristique
française s'est pas dû au smic c'est
pareil dans tous les pays développés
c'est pareil en grande bretagne
l'explication c'est l'effet perroquet
les entreprises choisissent lorsqu'elles
peuvent le travailleur le mieux qualifié
pour un poste même si ce poste a priori
ne demande pas des grandes qualification
c'est vrai aussi qu'à une différence
importante du taux d'emploi entre les
qualifiés et les non qualifiés
mais la france exactement à la moyenne
européenne et toute la politique
d'exonération des bas salaires n'a pas
fait que la france que que cet écart
s'est réduit en france plus que dans les
dents les dans les autres pays
donc
évidemment nous avons toujours des
économistes qui nous sortent des études
brillantes dans lequel ils disent en
fait au niveau du smic l'élasticité
c'est pas à 0,8 ces deux
problèmes c'est que ça s'appuie sur un
épisode extrêmement particulier d'une
période où les entreprises étaient en
train de le débaucher
effectivement
un moment donné les entreprises qui
bénéficiaient de cotisation de
réductions de cotisations sociales ont
créé 40 euros
licenciés 40 mille personnes de moins
que les autres le problème c'est que ce
que font cahuc et car si dios et tu
multiplies ce 40 par 20 pour dire si on
polarise les exonérations de cotisations
sociales sur les bas salaires on va
créer un nombre important d'emplois mais
on n'a pas le droit de multiplier par
vingt une expérience tout à fait
particulière la france a déjà beaucoup
d'exonération bas salaires et le
résultat c'est
ne peut pas être extrapolée à l'infini
et ça pose ce développement des emplois
à bas salaires ça pose d'autres
problèmes le développement de la
pauvreté dans un certain nombre de
familles qu'il a fallu compenser par le
rsa
le le
le travail précaire le travail à mi
temps etc etc donc je pense pas que
c'est aujourd'hui la piste qu'il fallait
suivre lorsque il est question de faire
de pacte de responsabilité et de
demander aux entreprises de de montée en
gamme d'être compétitive de
de faire de la recherche et
développement on a une stratégie qui
était peut-être nécessaire
mais
on peut pas prolonger
qu'on peut pas prolonger à l'infini
ensuite vous poser une seconde question
sur le financement de la protection
sociale
qui est une
question délicate vous savez que
dans la protection sociale
ce que je vous dirais très banal il est
convenu distinguer
les prestations contributive et les
prestations non contributives les
cotisations contributive les cotisations
non contributifs les cotisations
contributive le chômage la retraite les
prestations maladie y sommes
en espèces il est normal qu'elle soit
payée par les
salariés couverts que ce soit
proportionnelle ou
aux actifs couverts que cela
proportionnelle aux revenus que ce soit
proportionnelle aux
revenus d'activité
en ce qui concerne les retraites
personnellement je ne serais pas choqué
si à l'avenir on augmentait les
cotisations salariales des
monumentales les cotisations des
salariés
de sorte que le choix que pourront faire
les ménages entre partir plus ou moins
tôt à la retraite conserver un niveau de
retraite satisfaisant ça soit payée par
les actifs eux mêmes
et que ça pèse pas trop sur les sur les
entreprises par contre dans le système
français est effectivement on a
on a un héritage du passé qui sont les
cotisations
familles et les cotisations maladie en
nature qui continuent à peser sur des
cotisations sociales entre employeur et
qui pose un problème de
de cohérence donc ce problème de
cohérence on l'a résolu au cours du
temps parce que là on a taxé de plus en
plus les revenus du capital donc on a
les prélèvements sociaux qui pèsent sur
les revenus du capital et aujourd'hui on
peut considérer que les prélèvements
sociaux qui pèsent sur les revenus du
capital correspondent à peu près aux
cotisations sociales qui pèsent sur
les les salariés
et donc
que le système français
qui peut sembler un peu un peu bizarre
et finalement pas très différent des
systèmes à la scandinave où il ya un
prélèvement à la source extrêmement
important qui couvrent effectué à
l'impôt sur le revenu
extrêmement important qui couvre les
prestations maladie et les prestations
famille et qui est donc prélevé à la
source et nous lasser l'équivalence et
les cotisations sociales employeurs et
et la csg donc du ce2 de sorte que
toutes grandes réformes dans lequel on
dirait on va fusionner les cotisations
sociales employeurs la csg et l'impôt
sur le revenu vous créer un grand impôt
citoyen nous rapprocherait évidemment du
modèle suédois mais
ça changerait pas fondamentalement les
choses
parce que d'ores et déjà les reculs et
les revenus du capital contribuer à la
sécurité sociale ça changerait les
choses pour les retraités
ce que les retraités eux ne payent pas
je ne supporte pas de cotisations
maladie et famille sont pas d'employeur
qui payent des cotisations maladie ou
famille pour eux mais comme on est
engagé dans un processus où petit à
petit le niveau de vie des retraités va
baisser à cause des réformes il paraît
difficile de faire une réforme dont le
but serait de baisser encore le niveau
de vie des des retraités et donc on
bloque un put sur l'idée d'une grande
réforme du financement de la protection
sociale favorable à l'emploi
il ya une piste que je peux vous
indiquer mais qui a été unanimement
refusé
qu'ils refusaient par beaucoup de monde
ça consiste à dire après tout
les cotisations familles et malades ils
doivent être financés par une prestation
qui est de type impôts
les entreprises d'un bénéficient
des prestations famille parce que ça
permet ça leur permet d'avoir des
salariés
qui n'ont pas gardé les enfants ça
renouvelle la force de travail et
bénéficient début des prestations
maladie parce qu'ils ont besoin de
salariés en bonne santé donc n'est pas
illogique que les entreprises
contribuent à la protection sociale et
donc mais on peut changer l'assiette
au lieu d'avoir simplement une assiette
cotisations masse salariale on pourra
avoir une assiette valeur ajoutée et
donc la réforme possible ce serait de
changer l'assiette des cotisations pour
passer à une assiette valeur ajoutée qui
aujourd'hui est possible puisque on a
créé une cotisation sur la valeur
ajoutée des entreprises pour les
collectivités locales on pourrait la
faire monter en puissance pour financer
la protection sociale oke sinner
c'est une réforme qui a souvent été
évoquée cas souvent été rejetée elle a
désavantagé des mérites elle al'avantage
que l
permettrait à toutes les branches de
financer de manière plus égale la
protection sociale elle al'avantage de
favoriser les entreprises de main
d'oeuvre au détriment des entreprises
trop 4 capitalistique elle al'avantage
de décourager la substitution capital
travail le problème c'est que
beaucoup estiment que ces régressif qu'
il faut continuer à encourager le fait
d'utiliser plus de travail plus de
capital et mois de travail
donc
je ne pense pas le financement de la
protection sociale tel qu'il est
organisé aujourd'hui est un peu
compliqué mais il est pas foncièrement
pas foncièrement juste puisque on fait
payer les revenus du capital puisque la
particularité de la france c'est que les
salariés les plus élevés contribuent sur
la totalité de leur salaire ou aux
cotisations
familier et
maladies et puis on a un choix à faire
est ce que continue ce système où on a
si le
le
le financement de la protection sociale
sur uniquement la base massa salariale
ou est-ce qu'on va sur une base plus
large voilà
je vous remercie monsieur directeur très
rapidement je dirais simplement que
facialement vous convenez que le système
n'est quand même pas spécialement
lisible mais aimé que finalement il
reste il devient juste parce qu'on a
établi des d'état de correction
finalement qui qu'ils rendent
pratiquement
équilibré mais il faut dire que
facialement ces porcs est totalement de
votre avis c'est pas l'idéal je suis
totalement je suis totalement de votre
avis d'accord c'est pour ça que on a le
choix entre deux
deux réformes possibles la grande
réforme où on dit on va arranger les
choses pour que tout soit bien pour qui
a pas de problème et puis ce qu'on
appelle les bricolages qui aboutissent
aux mêmes qui consiste à combler les
congrès les défauts et dire ah bah c'est
scandaleux les revenus du capital
contribue pas assez donc on fait un
prélèvement social qui lie à sir
apparaît comme un rajout stupide donc
j'avais bien suivi votre premier oui non
et bien bien je vous remercie donc pour
ce propos très très intéressant et je
vais donc passer la parole à notre
rapporteur michelle demessine qui je
n'en doute pas à des questions à vous
poser
moi j'ai bon j'ai bien suivi votre
raisonnement
donc globalement
ce qu'on peut dire c'est que l'essentiel
de la politique
pour l'emploi est essentiellement et
budgétairement essentiellement assise
sur les ogres les exonérations de
charges sociales
notamment
sur les bas salaires avec une efficacité
qui est contestable avec des rivaux
notamment de trappe à bas salaires
donc il ya un doute important de
l'efficacité d'une dépend d'une aussi
grande dépense
publique alors même qu'on va la
prolonger puisque on va passer là avec
le pacte de responsabilité de 20 à 50
milliards
donc c'est une grande interrogation
donc c'est c'est pas le selon vous c'est
pas le bon chemin mais estimez vous
qu'il est possible
d'interrompre cette politique
de manière radicale sans dommage donc ça
c'est la première question la deuxième
question c'est est ce que est ce que le
soutien en fait avec cette politique
elle
va vers plusieurs objectifs sans qu'il
soit d'ailleurs bien défini un
l'objectif de d'inverser la courbe du
chômage deuxièmement de permettre aux
salariés non qualifiés de d'accéder plus
facilement
au travail et en plus d'apporter
plus de compétitivité
donc
estimez-vous donc qu on peut remplir
avec une seule un seul tuyau ces trois
objectifs à la fois ça c'est encore une
autre question est est-ce qui est ce
qu'il n'aurait pas fallu pour être plus
efficace puisque l'ensemble de cette
dépense publique qui est passé de 7,8
millions sur la première phase à
8 milliards à 20 milliards
est ce que est ce que
vous ne pensez pas que
l aurait dû tête elle aurait dû être
mieux ciblés alors pas seulement sur les
salaires mais peut-être sur des secteurs
en particulier je pense aux petites
entreprises aux pme qui qui me semble
t'il ont besoin d'un soutien plus
important ou plus ciblés plus ciblée
vers vers des secteurs
d'activité jeu on a bien de parler que
y'a loi de l'industrie
donc est-ce que la solution serait un
meilleur ciblage même si on sait qu' il
ya une très grande difficulté parce
qu'on peut pas avec les règles
européennes
et ou sinon
si si
quelle serait
l'alternative
à cette politique de manière concrète et
rapide quoi
comme vous que vous préconisez
une autre question je vais là dire tout
de suite
c'est sur le débat autour parce qu'on
parle du coût du travail tout est assis
sur le coût du travail tout est observée
à travers le coût du travail or
évidemment et beaucoup disque à beaucoup
d'autres paramètres qui entrent en ligne
de compte et ceux là sont pas
suffisamment observer et après il ya le
fameux débat sur le coût du capital donc
qui entre les qui entrent aujourd'hui un
petit peu en ligne de compte qui entre
en débat sent qu'il ya un véritable
débat sur cette question
au moins un débat public or il nous a
été dit dans le cadre des auditions
qu'il y aurait
des études de l'insee non publiée qui
compte est justement
la la
la stratégie autour du coût du capital
en particulier on nous a dit que
ce qui pouvait donner l'impression que
qui aurait eu un transfert entre entre
le travail et capital
deviendrait particulièrement du fait que
le poids des dividendes serait
statistiquement grossi
par par la méthode de calcul
dédoublant qui seraient imputables la
multiplication des filiales qui
reversent des dividendes c'est un peu
compliqué on n'a pas été très bien
d'ailleurs on reste on va chercher à
aller plus loin sur cette question mais
en face c'est ce qui alimenterait à on a
vu la réflexion du gouvernement sur ce
sujet
je vous réponde la deuxième question
c'est
c'est plus facile
d'accord regardable
quand on regarde
mais je je je peux vous faire passer le
document là dessus quand on regarde
l'évolution du partage de la valeur
ajoutée des sociétés
françaises d'abord il faut faire ça
honnêtement c'est à dire faire ça en est
c'est à dire regardez les dividendes
nets versés par les entreprises en
enlevant naturellement les et les
dividendes qu'elles reçoivent
puisque il d'abord la montée du net la
montée du brut c'est c'est la
financiarisation le fait que les
entreprises s'échangent déduits dans le
sens dans propre porte et donc on voit
que la part des dividendes est passé de
3 à 8% du pib si vous comparez l'année
72 o
ces dernières années il ya un phénomène
qui explique ça en même temps c'est la
diminution du poids des intérêts puisque
jadis on avait beaucoup d'inflation donc
les intérêts étaient gonflés
artificiellement
par l'inflation aujourd'hui les intérêts
sont très bas et donc jadis les
les actionnaires bénéficier à la fois
deux des dividendes et de la
dépréciation l'endettement due à
l'inflation
aujourd'hui ils en bénéficient mois on
cumule
une partie du phénomène qui est dû à ça
donc on peut corriger
le problème que nous avons c'est que
qu'on compare corrige on s'aperçoit que
à peu près en
73 et
aujourd'hui la part des revenus du
capital n'a pas foncièrement vous mentez
le problème c'est que les entrelacs
croissance n'est plus du tout la même
puisqu'en 72 on avait une croissance de
l'ordre de 4,5 pour cent par an
aujourd'hui
on est à 1,5 donc le besoin
d'investissement est beaucoup plus
faible aujourd'hui et donc les
entreprises avec le même profit
investissent beaucoup moins
et donc on peut dire comme neuf certains
travaux va bien circulez ya rien à voir
la part des 10 des profits n'a pas
foncièrement augmenté de l'autre côté on
peut dire comparé
à l'investissement qui réalise
la part des profits à est restée la même
et les entreprises n'investissent plus
et du coup
c'est trois points 4 points
d'investissement qui nous manque et ben
ça nous fait un déséquilibre
macroéconomique et ce déséquilibre
macroéconomique
quand vous regardez bien aujourd'hui il
est comblé par du déficit public
évidemment si les entreprises
investissaient
les quatre points pipe qui manquent on
sera en meilleure situation donc on peut
dire les entreprises n'investissent pas
assez compte tenu de leur niveau de
dividende et donc
il faut dire aux capitalistes
de manière ironique main on vous laisse
le choix
soit
on vous prend vos dividendes soit vous
les utiliser pour investir
voilà vous avez donc pu suivre
l'audition de louis gallois devant la
mission commune d'information sur
l'impact sur l'emploi des exonérations
de charges patronales et salariales très
bonne suite de programmes sur public
sénat
non